sur cette autoroute au nord de Kiev les
forces ukrainiennes en position
de l'autre côté invisible sur ses photos
mais bien présentes des troupes russes
qui avancent inexorablement sur la
capitale ukrainienne sous le feu les
soldats se replient temporairement à
l'abri sous le pont
bien moins puissante que son adversaire
l'armée ukrainienne résiste mais combien
de temps le siège de Kiev va-t-il durer
la nuit dernière plusieurs explosions
dans le ciel de la capitale dont
celle-ci selon les autorités
ukrainiennes un missile russe intercepté
par la défense anti-aérienne
les débris seraient retombées dans ce
quartier de l'Est de Kiev sur cet
immeuble résidentiel
une nuit d'effroi pour les habitants
frappés par la guerre des dizaines
d'appartements ont été soufflés au moins
trois blessés au moment de l'impact de
nombreux résidents étaient réfugiés dans
les caves
il était 4h du matin environ ma mère
s'est mise à crier réveille-toi il y
avait de la poussière des cris
l'armée russe resserre son étau selon
son commandement elle tient l'aéroport
militaire à l'ouest de Kiev
nous avons débarqué des forces
aéroportées avec succès elles ont
rejoint nos unités à l'aéroport que nous
contrôlons désormais nous bloquons Kiev
par l'Ouest
à 80 km au nord à ivankif l'armée
ukrainienne aurait détruit ce pont pour
empêcher l'avancée des troupes russes de
violents combats comme a dit mère et
plus près du centre dans le quartier de
bolonski les militaires Ukrainiens sont
en alerte permanente
on les voit qu'ici obligé de quitter
leur quartier général pour se déployer
dans l'urgence en emportant avec eux des
caisses de munitions tension maximum et
précaution dans cette base les soldats
brûlent les documents militaires
confidentiels pour qu'ils ne tombent pas
aux mains de leur ennemi en cas d'assaut
pour prêter main forte à son armée
professionnelle le ministère de la
Défense encourage les volontaires à
prendre les armes on voit ici des
habitants se servir dans les caisses de
munitions
dans le centre de Kiev le déploiement de
nouvelles forces sous les
applaudissements d'habitants qui veulent
croire que leur armée peut résister face
à la seconde puissance militaire
mondiale